scp-106 is like something out of a night
terror that gray Rotting Flesh those
wide empty eyes like those of a shark
that Relentless corrosion and Decay that
follows him everywhere but what if I
told you that beneath that horrifying
exterior was a heartbreaking tragic
backstory some of our more eagle-eyed
viewers know that scp-106 has a wide
variety of potential origin stories
different events that may have led to
the old man we all know and fear today
so this is just one of several
hypothetical backstories with that
little caveat out of the way it's time
to see if we can bring a tear to your
eye with the tragic tale of
scp-106 back in the year 2000 Dr Robert
Scranton and his wife Dr Anna Lang were
head researchers at site 120. the two of
them shared a lot of things a home a
life a shared love of Bon Jovi songs but
one of the things they had in common was
a passion for experimental research the
two worked together to develop a device
called The Lang Scranton stabilizer
which was an early prototype of the
reality anchors used by the SCP
Foundation to this day during a round of
routine tests an earthquake unexpectedly
struck site 120. Dr Scranton was working
in reality lab a when the ground beneath
him began to rumble the LSS shook from
the activity components sliding out of
place or breaking off altogether by the
time the guards and Dr Lang arrived to
inspect the scene both Dr Scranton and
the LSS control panel were gone upon his
disappearance Dr Scranton was initially
presumed dead however five years 11
months and 21 days later his whereabouts
became clear on December 23 2005 the LSS
control panel reappeared in Psych 120's
reality lab a it was covered in unknown
organic matter and wreaked a vomit blood
and death as Dr Anna Lang wandered into
the area against the warnings of her
colleagues she was overwhelmed with
grief and horror she choked back tears
as she accessed the control panel
retrieving the audio files left there
and realized that Dr Scranton had been
keeping a log of his time in whatever
place the disaster had sent him the
husband she had lost had in a way come
back to her but she could not see him
she could hear his voice but where was
he there was so much blood so much
unidentified organic matter it looked
like something had exploded onto the
control panel and she didn't want to
think about what or who that could have
been as Robert's wedding ring fell to
the floor Landing in the muck the
emotional strain became too much for Dr
Lang she collapsed onto the ground
hitting her head on the pavement Dr Lang
survived her fall left only with a
tender spot on her skull and a wealth of
question she was almost too afraid to
answer but she had to find out with
answers at her fingertips she had to
know what had become of her dear Robert
so with the help of the other side 120
researchers who promised to step in when
it became too painful Dr Lang began to
go through the audio archives left
behind by her lost love in the years
since he had vanished for the first
eight days Dr Scranton didn't speak at
least not in any recognizable words he
hyperventilated he muttered to himself
he sobbed he screamed with pure rage and
despair but he didn't say any word he
paced around the new space clawing for a
way out throwing his shoulder against
any hard surface he could in an attempt
to burst open a door but he was trapped
on his 11th day in the pocket Dimension
outside of any world he knew Dr Scranton
began to speak he reminded himself
reminded anyone who might someday listen
who he was Robert Scranton age 30 9 born
September 19
1961 favorite color blue favorite song
Living on a Prayer life Anna every day
he repeated these simple truths seeking
comfort in his memories of Anna and the
life they once shared her green eyes
their wedding day her dressed in white
shoving a piece of cake into his face
with a giddy laugh and a sparkle in her
eye he hoped that she was okay that she
had managed to escape the chaos with her
life but she had been spared a similar
fate he repeated her nickname the
password he had set for the control
panel Anna bobana at this point he
realized that the machine was still
recording he called out for help
desperate to see if anyone could hear
him is anyone there hello anyone anyone
but of course there was no answer why
the hell is this thing even working it
can't be working amused what the hell he
couldn't see anything not the switches
or the knobs only the blinking of the
red recording light he was growing
hungrier and thirstier by the day and
though he knew he should be dead from
dehydration by now somehow he wasn't he
was still alive soon he found the
controls and determined he had been
trapped in this place for two weeks
three days 47 hours and 58 minutes he
realized at this point that no matter
how hungry he got no matter how long he
went without water he would not die
somehow in this place his body kept
going his heart ticked along far past
what should have been his expiration
date he retrieved a small picture of
Anna from his pocket gazing at her face
by The Faint glow of the red light two
months four days and three hours in he
recorded a formal message my name is
Robert Scranton I'm a former head
researcher of sight
120 a foundation facility dedicated to
studying various reality bending scps
for the purpose of developing more
advanced countermeasures towards such
threats for the last Red Lights speak to
me two months eight days 16 hours uh
what the red light said I have been
trapped in what I believe to be an empty
pocket Dimension alone yeah alone all
alone I'm calling this place SCP
um I don't know I can't even remember
where we are screw it I don't know
what's happened in the past red light
please again two months eight days 16
hours but no one else is around to argue
and at this point I'm just talking into
this control panel to keep myself
together I I need to keep a record there
might be some poor chap in the future
who ends up like me and if this
eventually actually makes it out maybe
maybe I can help stop that from
happening that's all I have going for me
right now and I really need something to
go for
it so yeah Robert Scranton documenting a
new SCP for future research purposes
that'll have to do here we go a few days
later he added to his informal SCP log I
don't know if we could contain wherever
I am it's definitely not on Earth to be
honest I don't know where it is honey I
think it has something to do with the
stabilizer prototype I'll explain that
more later
um okay uh yeah wherever I am I don't
think it can be contained much as
created no no that's not the word
um entered yeah entered is better I came
into this place because of some really
bad reality bending accident no no
Robert don't be like that yet you don't
know if there's no exit yet uh
this place it's some sort of reality Gap
I think it's dark really dark as in this
little red light that shows my words are
actually being recorded is the only
visible light in this entire place I
can't even see my hands and I can barely
see the control panel here I've had to
basically use the light as a center and
remember how many steps I take and in
which direction I haven't gone past 100
yet
I'm too too scared to I wonder if my
hair is turning white right now I can't
even see what color it is anymore
speaking of which my head has been a bit
itchy recently if I don't concentrate on
it it's fine but I feel this tingling
all over my face I'm not sure why I I
just discovered a new property of this
place all this time I've been thinking I
may be walking on some sort of flat
ground if you will I keep eye contact
with the little red light as far as I
could see and it seems I could walk in a
straight flat path Jesus my head is
buzzing right now I think the adrenaline
is still kicking but if if my hypothesis
is correct and this really is some sort
of reality void then there shouldn't be
anything to walk on now that I think
about it the whole time I've been here
it felt like I'm walking but also I'm uh
swimming through something it's like I'm
walking through really thick black gel
there's enough tension to keep me on a
Surface but find a imagine myself
pressing down hard enough I I can
descend wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I I think I need to test this
more I'll be back two months 17 days two
hours navigation is largely affected by
conscious impulses to travel in a
certain direction so this definitely
isn't a complete reality Gap at least
according to mine and honest theories
if it were I wouldn't be able to move at
all since space wouldn't have existed
okay okay this makes a lot more sense
than it did before great great job
Robert okay you're getting there come to
think of it I should have realized that
sooner when I was able to move in a flat
plane to and from the little red it also
explains why I'm Not Dead from
dehydration or hunger yet time barely
passes in here okay yeah so I stood
right next to low red and went straight
down okay from here on out imagine
little red as the origin of a 3D space I
went um
down yeah right and then then I was able
to come back up to little red again I've
also been able to Fly Above red movement
in here is slow like I said gel analogy
but best I can describe it as Robert
became more and more familiar with his
surroundings with the truth of where he
found himself something became clear of
all the things in this new reality he
and his little red light were the
realest with time they would begin to
degrade to fall apart he had an
estimation three years before he would
be gone for good he had to try and look
for an end to this place a way out what
did he have to lose as it turned out
what he had to lose was himself he
couldn't feel his legs anymore couldn't
keep a grip on his own body he ran in
one straight line for six months but
found no Edge no end in sight he went
down for eight months straight and never
hit bottom his sole companion was the
little red light and he continued to
talk to it as if it ever answer his
hands began to phase into each other the
Integrity of his form beginning to fade
in war no matter what happened to him he
could not die his sanity began to
crumble his voice breaking into
uncontrollable Psalms and hysterical
laughter whoever Robert Scranton had
been he was gone he was something else
now and who knew how long that new thing
would last for the next 25 years Dr Anna
Lang tried her best to put the thought
of her lost husband out of her head it
almost worked some days she almost
forgot that hole in her heart then one
fateful day site 120 received a deadly
visitor
scp-106 reached through the back wall of
her lab dripping its horrible rot all
over the floor it grabbed for her its
touch melting her lab coat as she tore
away from its toothless grin the
singular focus and its milky eyes the
old man chased her down pushing past a
guard's bullets tearing through
everything in its path she had done
enough work on dimensional anomalies to
recognize one when she saw it and this
was one of the most destructive she had
ever encountered when it finally caught
her it said one word red then another
one that made her eyes fill with tears
Dr Robert Scranton had found a way to
escape the dead end prison he had fallen
into that gap between worlds all it had
taken was giving up his Humanity letting
that world rearrange his atoms and make
him something monstrous something that
destroyed all it touched he couldn't
remember why he needed to find Anna how
he had been separated from her for so
long he could only remember that he
wanted her wanted to be with her wanted
to touch her again even as she screamed
and melted in her hands
scp-106 was once a man just like any
other man what he is now shares that
vague shape of the human he used to be
the Vegas hints of his memories but that
is where the similarities end like the
Rotting Flesh of his body might suggest
he is little more than a shambling
corpse with a ravenous appetite for
violence Dr Robert Scranton is dead but
he will never rest now go check out
scp-106 the old man tail until death and
scp-106 the Old Man origin theories for
more on the twisted and terrifying
origins of scp-106